der einmalige waren okay der zuerst zu
wissen
herzlich kommen wieder leute helfen
kommen an einem ganz anderen ort als
sonst normalerweise sieht er mich von
meinem schreibtisch den jetzt gerade bin
ich im auto denn ich bin auf dem weg zur
wahl grill
wir haben dem titel gesehen heute wir
werden heute den kopf des spiels von
papa probieren einige völlig offen legen
sie bestimmt jetzt gerade ich habe keine
ahnung was abgeht ganz konnte zusammen
was für euch rappt er ist ein deutscher
rapper bin ich früher auch sehr sehr oft
gehört habe quartal ist unter anderem
dafür bekannt dass der gute musik macht
andererseits aber auch dafür dass er an
einem gold oder ob teilgenommen hat in
dem mehrere millionen wert von gold
entwendet wurden für den er auch einige
jahre im gefängnis gesessen hat und
seine gefängniszeit ist eigentlich grund
warum jetzt gerade hier sind denn er hat
im gefängnis ein interview gegeben und
in diesem interview erzählt er im
gefängnis saß hat die reporterin ihn
gefragt was er denn machen wollen würde
als erstes wenn er rauskommt und da hat
er mit so einer sehnsucht gesagt dass
ihr einköpfte spies will dass das ist
als die leute das mitbekommen haben zum
richtigen geworden ist irgendwann was
ist das erste was du machst wenn du raus
kommst das allererste ich glaube ich
gibt mir schön capstone schön köpfte
schließlich weiß auch nicht warum leute
aber es gibt dieses körperlich wie es
mir dass leute somit richtig
leidenschaftlich
mit gar kein reden so schön kraft der
spieß kolbstraße einköpfte spiels erst
mal mit gar keinen reden hoch und so
dieses - so groß geworden und so schlaue
unternehmer dass wir einfach dass man
sonst mal vor augen halten aufgrund
eines teams im internet einen laden
aufgemacht hat der laden heißt ein paar
war grill in bonn
weil deswegen weil ich gesagt habe was
gibt mir einfach nur ein kräftig ist
aber es gibt mir einfach nur ein kräftig
richtig wenn das geld ist das einfach
jetzt schon auf grund von - einfach nur
von - im internet laden aufgemacht
werden aber die erste mal von fahrzeugen
der laden war geist aber laufen ich bin
sehr gespannt wie es ist wir fahren
jetzt von köln nach bonn und probieren
im kräftespiel leute wir sind in bonn
wir sind in meiner geburtsstadt und es
ist nicht mehr weit
einfach mit gar keine rede nein ein
kräftiges was wäre es jetzt möchte ich
das wieder nicht damit die leute
aufgestellt
hier ist der parkgarage hätte ich mir
was den ausgang finden dann ist es nicht
mehr weit
doch mal hier die anderen vermissten das
lange freigehalten
der einmalige waren kürzlich in dem
persönlich ab
aber du weißt du denn so weit dass haben
das nicht mehr geredet mit gar keinen
redens ich freue mich ganz ehrlich leute
weißt du kennst noch hören dass man den
ohnehin mit ihm reden gestellt
wahrscheinlich ist 2 und 1 verlassen so
nicht und sollte ja auch noch einen
eigenen angeboten seinen schönen falsche
neidern aus dieser maschine
sie müssen entschuldigen weil es nicht
wenn er ab und zu so lädiert ist sogar
sehr praktisch
hier wie auch wir etwas falsch gemacht
haben
mit gar kein reden sogar leute wie soll
das sowie solltest du was werden na gut
dann komm einfach wieder gehen zuerst zu
wissen
aber man muss sie auch im körper ist
erstmal einarbeiten
er ist ein bisschen zittrig jetzt hier
so jetzt können wir langsam wir jetzt um
alles da das meet die soße
außerdem starb übrigens auch so wir
haben dafür komplett regulär bezahlt
alles bezahlen also nicht gesprochen ist
also was deswegen habt ihr jetzt auch
eine werbung ist ein held kommt der
erste richtige bis jetzt gar neben
gesehen wir sind jetzt red i wir sind
drin
[Musik]
doch wenn ich nicht was euer feedback so
weit bringt richtige auswahl an der
straße sagen der wirklichkeit trifft man
alle mitarbeiter von walter die den
ganzen tag die gleichen witze zu hören
bekommen ja das sagt denkt er ist lustig
aber wenn er drei mal am tag mit gar
keiner reden hört wird immer noch findet
übrigens tv wohnt sogar hier in bonn ihr
wohnzimmer studierst du wie schneidet
das so oft vergleich zu den anderen muss
man es machen aber niemand kann ebenso
es gibt eigentlich nicht so kollegen die
das hauptgericht anbieten hier so köpfte
und solche sachen
das wirst du vielleicht bin ich auch
überzeugt dass der markt
wenn man jetzt mal hier ist hast du die
ganze zeit diese minister glaubt immer
wenn ihr hier seid wenn ihr genau gleich
machen
ich glaube wir machen jetzt richtig viel
spaß sagt er das immer so als wäre er
dazu das habe ich dass ich noch nie
gesehen so das war ja wirklich euro
kündigen das war so ein großes becken
und wasser gezapft darauf es ist
wirklich
man muss eigentlich gerne kosten
gescheut ja nicht an impfdosen
superbayern das war wirklich gut -
kombiniert warum ich mache das einfach
aus der leckenden einfach der letzte
chance diesmal aber auf jeden fall jedes
mal von der seite so ich bin nicht so
ein krasser scharf es wohl geben dabei
letzte hat ein bisschen schon aber es
ist wirklich leid
ich finde so könnte fast noch mehr
fleisch ein
diese fleisch dann sehr schnell ich bin
einfach das fleisch und er ist eine art
kinder besser durchmischt dass du so
eine liste mit allen hast du nicht nur
immer so ein danach wissen einen nur
leicht wissen ob er das stimmt das
dabei kommen könnte man das auch so
bestellen
wir haben wir nun bestellt hatte das
hätte ich nie hatten und haben noch
keine cola leistung aber er hat was
jeden fall auch mit einkalkulieren
müssen am anfang jetzt gerade die
tageswache offen ist ob kastl
wartezeiten wir haben hier gewartet
20 minuten und zwanzig minuten laufen
gehen aber manchmal das stimmt oder
sogar für ausbauen kommt dann passt das
eigentlich aus köln verfahren wird es
natürlich auch ganz klein ist kann ich
mache jeden tag aber jetzt dafür leute
erst mal ruhe aufgegeben vielleicht über
feedback so natürlich nicht wieder auf
dem rückweg nach köln es war eine
relativ kurzer zwischenstopp in bonn
weil wir einfach nichts mehr zeit hatten
andrè musste der kreationismus den fan
war aber auch jeder muss deswegen ist es
in der kurzen zeit und kommen jetzt mal
zu unserem friedlich ich persönlich muss
sagen die schärfe gut gefallen ich bin
kein schärferes freak aber habe mich
daran gewöhnt dass müssen auch
wissenschaft zu essen es war geil
all you can drink mäßig heute das ist
noch mal zu sagen aber auch richtig geld
würde ich gut geschmeckt was zu sagen
ja also es ist für alle wirklich weil
die so im umkreis von bonn bonn schon
mal ein erlebnis war da hinzufahren
ich will aber auch ganz ehrlich mit euch
sein wird auch kritisch mit dem produkt
sein denn wie gesagt da ist nix
gesponsert oder so ich will auch dass
hier zu hause und gefühl bekommt wie das
möglich war und ich würde sagen es war
war durchaus lecker aber es war jetzt
nicht außerordentlich gut was wir zu
sagen ja ich will auch sagen dass dort
über lecker aber jetzt nicht denken dass
wir da musst du unbedingt mal gewesen
sein
einfach lecker lecker künftig und daher
glaube ich glaube ich habe ich auch also
wenn man selbst kann ich mir den ganzen
hype rausnimmt um haushalt und das
müssen sie sich mal so weiter so
entwickelt dann wenn das produkt gleich
mal für dich sagt dann wird es in
zukunft so sein dass alles wieder in
bonn sind fans von katar sind sorgt nun
da gerne mal hingehen einfach so für den
job und auch als weißer lecker ist so
aber ich glaube dass man zur ultra lange
wege auf sich nehmen
das ist für die meisten wahrscheinlich
da nicht das richtige wahl als mega
lecker aber es bleibt ein geschmack ich
nicht gut aber eben nicht
außergewöhnlich man muss allerdings auch
sagen dass wahrscheinlich die
wartezeiten für den daad ein bisschen
abnehmen werden wenn das erst wenn diese
eigenen gewöhnungsphase die
eröffnungsphase erste weise
das glaube ich dann auch wieder ein
pluspunkt so wir haben gewartet
die anderen werde ich nicht ich glaube
der keiler bieten frage gestellt wieso
leute spielen zu hause wir werden jetzt
noch um die zehn vollzumachen kennt das
spiel und weil sie sehr lustig sind ein
blick in die google bewertung zu
verweigere
das ist natürlich war vor zwei tagen
splash am no gibt fünf sterne villa
astronaut und habe meine
mondexpeditionen abgebrochen um den
kräfte spies von hertha auszuprobieren
hat sich gelohnt immer wieder gerne
alles klar scheint auch astronauten da
unterwegs markus freitag gibt einen
einen stern und kommentiert muss leider
sagen dass es mir nicht geschmeckt hat
und ich deutlich mehr erwartet habe
werde dort in zukunft nicht mehr essen
finde ich jetzt persönlich ein bisschen
harsch muss ich wirklich sagen also für
die erfahrung ich da gehabt habe
aber wenn man in der in bonn bord und
soll das ist auf jeden fall ins porto wo
man hingehen kann also das ist mir nicht
geschmeckt hat das kann ich jetzt
wirklich nicht sagen felix schreibt was
läuft köpfe spies ist geil kann nur
empfehlen um kinder auch gut ohne reden
und so ich freue mich wirklich auf die
leute überhaupt da waren sowie news
geben alle einfach nur irgendwelche
sprüche zitate da rein und waren die
waren überhaupt da ich glaube da als ich
meine es ist ja lecker so das ist ja
nichts verkehrt daran aber 1000 prozent
waren 95 prozent aller briefe
geschrieben und ich meine da man kann
dort seinen kräfte perfekt genießen ohne
reden aber ja leute so weit soll das an
der stelle gewesen sein die kriegt hier
drüben einen kauf des spiels für euch um
könnte meinen abonnieren ohne denen
wohlgemerkt ich bin an der schule
ausmacht
misrata